könnte man sagen man macht jetzt berlin
mitte dicht keiner kann hier raus ist
das eine möglichkeit um einen gesamt
shutter und zu verhindern
ja das wäre jedenfalls eine sehr
drakonische maßnahme wir haben das ja
erlebt wo hahn wurde so abgeregelt das
als in china funktioniert wir sehen uns
jetzt in madrid da funktioniert es nicht
so toll die stadt wurde abgeriegelt
die frage ist wie man das durchsetzen
kann dann müsste man also massiv
wahrscheinlich mit polizeikräften
arbeiten die menschen müssten sich daran
halten
aber wäre besser als locker und
wahrscheinlich das gesamt also ich denke
was wir sicherlich nicht wieder machen
sollten ist winter ersten welle einen
sein ansatz der für das ganze
bundesgebiet derselbe wäre
wir müssen also differenzieren ich
glaube das ist ein vorteil des
föderalismus das ist zwar natürlich mit
kommunikationsproblem betrachtet aber
das müssen wir hinkriegen dass es lokal
machen